[Musique]
bienvenue place Vendôme à Paris
considéré comme l'une des plus belles
places au monde aujourd'hui nous allons
découvrir de véritables trésors au sens
propre du terme ceux de la haute
joaillerie française un artisanat d'art
que le monde entier nous envie à la fin
du 19e siècle les plus grandes maisons
de Haute Joaillerie se sont installés
ici elles nous ont exceptionnellement
ouvert leurs portes nous permettant
ainsi de découvrir leur histoire leur
savoir-faire et leur joyau historiques
ils ont appartenu au plus grand au roi
aux rennes au Maharaja aux artistes au
star d'Hollywood entre autres pour le
filmer nous sommes allés aux quatre
coins du monde pour vous raconter une
histoire de France hors des sentiers
battus chaque joyau a sa légende et
avant tout un destin fabuleux
[Musique]
la haute joaillerie est un artisanat
d'art français que le monde entier nous
envie
des Orfèvres du Moyen-Âge aux grandes
maisons de la place Vendôme
la joaillerie française trouve ses
lettres de noblesse au 17e siècle en
parlant les têtes couronnées de France
et d'Europe des plus beaux joyaux
déjà les Égyptiens pensaient que les
bijoux étaient la chair des dieux et les
Mayas comparer l'éclat de l'or à la
lumière de l'astre solaire
tribu de pouvoir des puissants les
joyaux ont incarné au fil des siècles
fortunes séduction consécration complot
corruption et ruine
les plus grandes maisons de Haute
Joaillerie mais les rio di Meller Chomet
Boucheron quartier et ventes clafé
harperse nous ont exceptionnellement
ouvert leur porte elles nous ont permis
de découvrir leur collection privée qui
rassemblent les pièces historiques de
leur patrimoine mais aussi des joyaux
contemporains qui n'attendent plus que
d'être portées
de l'histoire de ces maisons au mariage
princier les plus prometteurs du 21e
siècle en passant par l'affaire du
collier de la reine les fastes de
l'Empire et les drames de la Seconde
Guerre mondiale nous découvrirons au
travers d'histoire rocambolesque comment
les pierres précieuses ont joué un rôle
politique majeur dans l'histoire de
France
avec les courtisanes de la belle époque
et les riches héritières des années 30
l'excentricité des joyaux sera également
à l'honneur enfin démarre à Jade des
années 20 aux actrices des années 50
nous découvrirons les commandes les plus
spectaculaires qui font l'histoire de la
joaillerie française sans oublier les
techniques des meilleures artisans qui
ont donné naissance aux œuvres les plus
rares
[Musique]
la plus ancienne des maisons de haute
joaillerie française et la maison
Mellerio dimeler mais il y a 400 ans
nous sommes un jour de 1780
Jean-Baptiste melllerio jeune colporteur
se presse aux portes du château de
Versailles pour proposer de merveilleux
bijoux aux riches courtisans de la cour
de France
[Musique]
il expose ses créations dans cette malle
qu'on appelle la marmotte
au même moment la reine Marie-Antoinette
rentre d'une promenade elle a 25 ans
elle adore les bijoux et se laisse
séduire par les créations de Mellerio
l'histoire de cette rencontre avec la
reine Marie-Antoinette a donné naissance
à une légende au sein de la famille
Mellerio
[Musique]
le jour où la reine a rencontré le jeune
Jean-Baptiste elle se serait offert ce
bracelet came
il y a des éléments qui corroborent
l'idée qu'il est plus appartenir à
Marie-Antoinette il y a des rubis qui
était une des pierres favorites de
Marie-Antoinette maintenant c'est
absolument impossible de prouver
effectivement que ce bracelet est bien
appartenu à Marie-Antoinette et bien sûr
à l'époque on ne poinçonnait pas on ne
gravait pas donc on n'a pas d'autres
éléments de preuves que simplement cette
tradition familiale quelle que soit son
origine la légende qui entoure ce
bracelet symbolise les liens très forts
qui unissent les melleriaux aux reines
et impératrice de France
[Musique]
aujourd'hui pour fêter ses 400 ans la
maison Mellerio a réalisé une collection
de bijoux exceptionnels qui leur rend
hommage
ce joyau est tout particulièrement dédié
à la reine Marie de Médicis elle est en
fait la première à leur avoir ouvert les
portes de la cour
nous avons créé une collerette qui
rappelle un petit peu les grands cols
des robes de Marie de Médicis
des milliers d'heures de travail une
pièce merveilleuse très légère très
souple donc on a une image de quelque
chose qui est peut-être un peu un peu
rigide et en fait pas du tout au porter
elle est complètement articulée et donc
elle est elle est fabuleuse
cette collerette d'une incroyable beauté
et faite de
500085 diamants et de 15 rubis la maison
Mellerio a mis plus de 30 ans pour
collecter l'ensemble de ces rubis c'est
cette double caractéristique d'être à la
fois un instrument de pouvoir et un
instrument qui sert la beauté qui fait
un peu l'intérêt et l'attraction de ce
métier tout à fait exceptionnel
au fil des siècles la maison Mellerio
s'est toujours tenue proche du pouvoir
royal mais aussi religieux
tout cela a commencé en 1613
accravezzia en Italie
cette vallée lombarde est alors un axe
de passage hautement stratégique
la région de France Marie de Médicis
accorde alors au commerçants de la
région une exonération des taxes
commerciales
en échange elle obtient l'assurance
qu'il laisseront passer les troupes
françaises
grâce à ces privilèges qui vont leur
ouvrir les portes de la cour assez
rapidement ils vont monter en gamme
comme on dit aujourd'hui et avoir une
clientèle et qui les accueillent
volontiers d'ailleurs de temps en temps
on écrit qu'ils sont les bienvenus à la
cour
[Musique]
de cette relation privilégiée avec le
pouvoir les melleriaux conservent un
trésor composé entre autres d'orfèvrerie
religieuse
[Musique]
alors ici vous avez un hostensoir qui
date de 1829 la 3 exemplaires qui ont
été faits par la famille un qui est
aujourd'hui au Vatican un autre qui est
à Notre-Dame de Paris et le troisième
dans notre petit village de cravédia
[Musique]
a été probablement on dirait aujourd'hui
le leader mondial dans le domaine de
l'orfèvrerie religieuse avec énormément
d'oeuvres qui sont dans toutes les
églises au Mont-Saint-Michel à
Notre-Dame de Paris mais aussi au
sacré-cœur c'est une tradition qui
exprime je dirais le désir des hommes je
dirais d'église ou de pouvoir de montrer
je crois une forme de foi ce n'est pas
simplement une forme magnificence est
aussi une forme de froid
ce trésor familial les gay à l'église
est également composé d'une précieuse
étoffe
[Musique]
nous avons ici en fait une les chasubles
qui en fait sont le résultat d'un don de
la famille de robe de Marie-Antoinette
et qui sont brodés sur je crois ce qui
était probablement la robe de mariée de
Marie-Antoinette
la reine Marie-Antoinette est connue
pour aimer les bijoux son goût immodéré
pour la joaillerie veulent à plonger
dans un scandale sans précédent c'est
l'affaire dite du collier de la reine
nous sommes à Versailles en 1772
marie-Antoinette est le futur roi Louis
XVI ne sont pas encore montés sur le
trône le roi Louis XV au crépuscule de
son règne et follement amoureux de sa
maîtresse madame Dubarry et la couvre
régulièrement de bijoux le joaillier
parisien Baumer qui fournit en ce temps
la cour de France va leur faire un pari
osé
fabriquer une pièce d'exception un
collier de diamant comme on en a encore
jamais vu d'une valeur de près d'un
million de livres
mais deux ans plus tard le roi Louis XV
meurt Activ vendre désormais le collier
quelques temps après le joaillier se
tourne vers Marie-Antoinette il n'y a
qu'une reine pour porter un bijou d'une
telle ampleur
il s'agit en fait de deux colliers un
tour de cou et un sautoir sur lesquelles
sont montés plus de 500 diamants épernes
d'une grande pureté
Marie-Antoinette aime beaucoup les
bijoux mais là on est au-delà du million
et à l'époque c'était l'équivalent de
trois petits chatons
ça l'a fait reculer elle y réfléchit à
deux fois elle se dit que si elle
accepte un présent de plus d'un million
de livres et bien sa réputation en
prendra un sérieux coup
la reine c'est que le peuple français ne
lui est pas favorable elle s'est aussi
que les contes de la couronne sont
devenus publics une dépense aussi
faramineuse ne pourrait donc pas rester
secret
à partir de 1781 le ministre Necker
institut une certaine transparence dans
les finances de l'État il publie les
comptes de la monarchie et donc l'emploi
des finances de l'État font l'objet de
débat public
face à l'offre alléchante du joaillier
Baumer Marie-Antoinette refuse donc ce
collier
rue ce mot historique il vaut mieux
acheter un navire de guerre que un bijou
mais elle ignore que dans l'ombre
quelqu'un complote pour récupérer ce
collier elle s'appelle Jeanne de la
Motte Valois
[Musique]
elle a fait croire aux joaillier Baumer
et bassanges que la reine envisageait
d'acheter le collier mais incognito dans
la plus grande discrétion vu le prix de
l'objet pour servir d'intermédiaire
Jeanne de Lamotte valoie le cardinal de
Rohan qui était prêt à tout pour
conquérir les faveurs de la reine Jeanne
de Lamotte Valois lui fait croire
qu'elle est une intime de
Marie-Antoinette elle lui aurait demandé
d'acheter le collier par le biais d'une
personne de confiance comme lui flatté
le cardinal de Rohan accepte de se
porter garant de cet achat secret auprès
du joaillier et bien sûr ces jeunes de
Lamotte Valois qui est chargée de
réceptionner le collier pour la reine
donc là Jeanne de Lamotte Valois
s'empare du collier évidemment ne le
remets pas à la reine le fait dépecer
toutes les pierres sont vendues
séparément et à cette partie là le
collier n'existe plus
les diamants qui composaient le collier
sont vendus en Angleterre par Jeanne de
Lamotte Valois et son amant
le mois d'août 1785 arrive les joaillés
n'ont toujours pas reçu la première
échéance du paiement et donc tout
naturellement il se tourne vers la reine
pour savoir ce qui se passe
rien toilette tombe de haut elle
découvre que un collier a été acheté en
son nom et à son insu tout de suite elle
pense que le grand coupable c'est le
cardinal de Rouen
le 15 août 1785 sur ordre de Louis XVI
le cardinal est arrêté au vu et au sud
toute la cour
l'affaire du collier se transforme en
affaires d'état
on ne tarde pas à penser dans l'opinion
que c'est un coup monté par la reine en
fait et donc cette affaire va se
retourner assez rapidement contre
Marie-Antoinette
tout le monde connaît le mépris de
Marie-Antoinette pour le cardinal de
Rohan personne ne peut imaginer que la
reine frivole et insouciante ce soit
privée de ce collier
l'opinion pense qu'elle a simplement
voulu la tête de Rohan c'est une affaire
au retombées dramatique
il y a eu plusieurs affaires d'état
associés à des bijoux mais celle du
collier de la reine et une des plus
importantes et elle intervient en
1785-86 on est à la veille de la
Révolution française elle est évident
qu'elle a eu des conséquences
n'ont pas sur le déclenchement de la
révolution mais sur la virulence que le
discours révolutionnaire a adopté contre
la reine il ne reste de ce collier
démonter en Angleterre en 1785 qu'un
dessin et c'est grâce à lui que nous
pouvons en admirer aujourd'hui une
fidèle reproduction dans les
appartements de Marie-Antoinette au
château de Versailles
la reine n'est pas la seule à aimer se
parer des plus beaux joyaux à chaque
sortie publique le roi Louis XVI se doit
de porter les plus belles pierres ce
sont les joyaux de la couronne de France
ainsi le 5 mai 1789 alors qu'ils se
rendent jusqu'à l'Assemblée des États
généraux Louis XVI et Marie-Antoinette
portent les pièces les plus symboliques
la reine a épinglé le Sancy dans sa
chevelure le roi porte lui à sa poitrine
l'insigne de la Toison d'Or ces trésors
de la couronne de France sont
aujourd'hui pour certains exposés au
Louvre c'est le roi François 1er qui
décide de constituer le trésor des
Diamants de la Couronne
qui devient donc un trésor qui
appartient à l'État qui est inaliénable
qui passe de souverains en souverain et
qui donc n'appartient pas en propre à
chaque souverain au fil du temps les
les souverains vont acquérir des pierres
particulièrement prestigieuses donc le
côtes de Bretagne et parmi les pierres
conservées l'une des plus anciennes le
régent plus tard ce diamant est le joyau
le plus important de la monarchie
française
découvert en 1698 en Inde il est
aujourd'hui considéré comme le diamant
le plus pur au monde il a fallu deux ans
de taille pour obtenir ce sentiment
parfait présenté à Louis XIV il ne
pourra jamais l'acquérir la pierre est
trop chère c'est donc Philippe d'Orléans
le région qui la chatte en 1714 le
régent sera monté sur les couronnes de
sacre de Louis XV et Louis XVI Louis XIV
va également bénéficier des pierres qui
avaient des collectionnées par Mazarin
donc il y a toute la collection des
mazarins des diamants qui portent le nom
de leur collectionneur initial
le 17 juin 1791 en pleine tourmente
révolutionnaire les joyaux de la
couronne font l'objet d'un inventaire il
décrit des coffres remplies de diamants
de pierres précieuses de rivières de
perles le tout équivalent à 7 tonnes
d'or
[Musique]
ces joyaux sont conservés en lieu sûr
dans ce que l'on appelle le garde-meuble
de la couronne située sur l'actuel place
de la Concorde dans ce qui est devenu
l'hôtel de la Marine durant 4 nuits du
13 au 17 septembre 1792 ce lieu est le
théâtre d'un pillage sans précédent il
faut imaginer cette classe aujourd'hui
ensoleillée pleine de monde déserte la
nuit elle est malfamée les gens n'aiment
pas s'y promener le soir
[Musique]
et voilà que
faire 10 heures du soir et cambrioleurs
arrivent de différentes directions
ils ont repéré une tringle de fer à
laquelle est accrochée une lanterne il
lance une corde l'attache à la tringle
monte à la corde arrive sur le balcon
qui est ici
l'un des cambrioleurs casse un des
carreaux et avec un vilebrequin creuse
un trou dans le volet le voilà c'est le
trou dans le volet qui était
bouché avec un morceau de bois mais on
voit très bien que c'était un morceau de
bois rajouté on ouvre les volets et on
rentre tranquillement dans cette pièce
ici puis ils ont commencé tout
simplement un crocheter les armoires les
commodes les tables et à sortir
méthodiquement puis au fur et à mesure
les trésors apparaissaient des montagnes
de pierrerie de toutes les couleurs et
de diamant
l'enthousiasme a gagné surtout qu'ils se
sont aperçus que personne ne venait les
déranger ce n'est qu'après ces quatre
nuits qu'une patrouille de garde
nationaux enfin alerté par des bruits
découvre l'incroyable cambriolage ce vol
plonge l'ensemble de la classe politique
révolutionnaire dans la stupéfaction des
1793 17 mal frats sont jugés un bandit
des hauteurs de Ménilmontant ressort
comme étant le cerveau de ce casque
insensé
étrangement au moment du procès les plus
gros joyaux de la couronne de France
refond surface quand déjà elle affaire
est assez avancée que les petits
cambréers sont arrêtés curieusement
voilà que soudain on retourne 3 ou 4 des
pièces historiques les plus importantes
de ce cambriolage en particulier le
diamant le régent probablement le plus
beau diamant du monde
en mars 1794 tous les grands diamants
sont de retour il était impossible de
les vendre même retailler ils sont
reconnaissables par tous
[Musique]
à la Révolution succédera le Premier
Empire de Napoléon on peut d'ailleurs
voir sur ses tableaux les portraits des
impératrices Joséphine et Marie-Louise
le Premier Empire est vraiment une
période très singulière dans l'histoire
de la joaillerie après les fastes de la
monarchie ce nouveau régime doit asseoir
son pouvoir en lui donnant une image et
surtout un patrimoine il peut alors
compter sur le joaillier Marie Étienne
Nito fondateur de la maison Chomet où je
me trouve à présent
le goût de Napoléon pour les bijoux et
politique ils sont avant tout le symbole
ultime de la puissance impériale et
c'est Mythos en personne qui va créer
les joyaux du sacre de Napoléon comme
vous allez le voir maintenant
nous sommes le 2 décembre 1804 dont
l'archevêché de la cathédrale Notre-Dame
de Paris Napoléon et Joséphine mettent
leurs habits de cérémonie il va être
sacré empereur elle va être couronnée
impératrice
la couronne du sacre de l'empereur a été
sertie par le bijoutier Marie-Etienne
Nito fondateur du joaillier Chomet et
qui est depuis deux ans le joaillier
attitré de Napoléon ce jour-là Napoléon
arbore son épée consulaire aujourd'hui
conservée précieusement au château de
Fontainebleau
Nito a fait sertir dans la garde de
l'épée un symbole d'exception
que décide-t-on de puiser dans le trésor
national le joyau le plus illustre de la
Couronne qui est le régent
c'est une idée qui est très importante
pour aider en termes de visibilité la
création de ce nouvel Empire français
Nito crée les bijoux qui offriront à
l'Empire français face et pouvoir
cet homme est un visionnaire il va
analyser le contexte économique et
social de son temps et il va comprendre
que l'élaboration de l'Empire français
est un tournant très important dans le
domaine de la politique mais aussi dans
le domaine des arts décoratifs
l'empereur comble le joaillier Nito de
fastueuse commande les joyaux reprennent
leur fonction royale ils servent
d'outils de communication mais c'est
peut-être à l'impératrice Joséphine que
la joaillerie parisienne doit le plus en
ce début de XIXe siècle joséphine est
l'une des plus grandes consommatrices de
bijoux et de mode les dépenses
excessives de l'impératrice agace
d'ailleurs fortement l'empereur
Joséphine reçoit régulièrement des
artisans dans ses appartements du palais
des Tuileries et leur passe de
somptueuse commande des artisans quand
ils parlent d'elle nous avons des
correspondances dans les archives de
Chaumet qui parle de Joséphine et qui se
souviennent de l'époque où il réalisait
pour elle les plus beaux bijoux et il
disait du temps de la bonne Joséphine
c'est une femme qui a toujours été
empreinte d'une grande beauté
chaque matin l'impératrice choisi parmi
ses bijoux celui qui ornera ses
splendides tenues en voici un exemple
[Musique]
cette magnifique parure est un bijou de
tous les jours elle est faite de perles
et d'un taille un procédé romain qui
consiste à graver les pierres à
l'intérieur
[Musique]
le couple impérial est un couple
amoureux mais en 1809 et faute
d'héritier il divorce
l'empereur signe l'acte de divorce à la
Malmaison il regarde Joséphine et il dit
elle a embelli mes plus belles années
il faut un Apollon un héritier le 2
avril 1810 si l'épouse donc en seconde
noces la fille de l'empereur d'Autriche
Marie-Louise
Marie-Louise à 18 ans elle a toute la
pigmentation le charme l'éducation les
ans d'une personne royale et ce qui est
intéressant sur ce tableau c'est que
elle porte sur elle des bijoux
extraordinaires réalisés par le
fondateur de Chaumet toujours par
l'intermédiaire du joaillier mytho
ilonore sa nouvelle épouse d'une parure
somptueuse il s'agit là d'un rare
témoignage des joyaux de la couronne
n'ayant subi aucune modification qui
nous soit parvenue la période de
romantique on s'inspire beaucoup de
certains bijoux du Trésor de la couronne
de France des joyaux de la couronne du
18e
la monture faite de grappes de raisin et
de feuilles de vigne en or préfigurent
le style romantique qui sera la mode
quelques 20 années plus tard
[Musique]
Napoléon est fasciné par l'Empire romain
il va donc réhabiliter le port du
diadème désormais il impose à toutes les
femmes de porter ce type de bijou à sa
cour
c'est un peu le passeport d'une femme
dans la haute société
on lui offre pour son mariage un diadème
alors que sa bague de fiançailles doit
être quelque chose d'extrêmement discret
[Musique]
ce diadème du joyeux mytho date de 1811
il est typique de l'époque il représente
des épis de blé c'est ce que l'on
appelle un bijou naturaliste
ce style représente toutes sortes de
végétaux et d'animaux
ce diadème est très émouvant parce que
les épis de blé sont
articulées et ils sont disposés de telle
manière qu'on a l'impression qu'ils sont
balayés par le vent
[Musique]
depuis sa création et à la faveur de ses
liens avec le pouvoir la maison Nito
devenue Chaumet s'est fait une
spécialité des diadèmes
[Musique]
je me trouve ici dans le salon des
diadèmes de la Maison Chaumet le diadème
EPIDE blé dont nous venons de parler se
trouve juste là c'est une pièce unique
de la collection historique de la maison
autre pièce exceptionnelle ce collier
serpou de 1906 en diamant et platine il
est entièrement articulé ce qui le rend
extrêmement souple à la belle époque les
femmes le portaient le soir avec des
robes très décolletées aujourd'hui la
nouvelle collection de la maison chemin
lumière d'eau reprend cette idée de
souplesse et ce thème fort qui est le
style naturaliste regardez par exemple
cette magnifique parure
elle se compose d'une montre manchette à
secrets en platine et cadran en acres
serti de diamants de boucles d'oreilles
en platine et or blanc et d'un somptueux
collier en platine et diamant
cette parure est directement inspirée
d'un diadème naturaliste de 1904 et
illustre parfaitement l'évolution de ce
style propre à la maison Chomet ainsi
les éléments de la nature n'en finissent
pas d'inspirer les créateurs de haute
Joëlle
le 19e siècle est le siècle des grands
bouleversements politiques c'est aussi
le ton du développement du goût pour les
arts décoratifs la culture et les arts
se répandent dans une grande partie de
la société Paris est le théâtre des
grands chantiers et c'est à la faveur de
ce nouvel urbanisme que la rue de la
Paix voit le jour en 1806 sous le nom de
rue Napoléon
les joyers sont encore des artisans qui
travaillent dans l'ombre de leurs
ateliers proches des lieux de pouvoir le
Palais Royal et ses petites russes
environnantes sont pleines de petits
artisans comme la famille melllerio il y
avait toute la vie de famille qui était
au septième et 8e étage et où il vivait
à l'italienne et puis au rez-de-chaussée
alors là c'était la splendeur où les
clients venaient justement pour
découvrir leurs bijoux il y avait un
espèce de contraste absolument
incroyable entre cette vie un peu à
l'ancienne et puis cette splendeur qui
avait dans les boutiques qui étaient au
rez-de-chaussée
et les melleriaux sont les premiers
joyers à ouvrir boutique sur cet axe qui
relie l'opéra au palais des Tuileries le
succès de la rue de la Paix ne sera
jamais démenti
au ce sont en fait propulsés les tous
premiers rues de la paix un moment où il
y avait absolument aucun commerce de
joaillerie dans cet endroit donc c'était
je dirais faire preuve certaines
capacités d'anticipation
quelques décennies très mouvementées
plus tard à l'aube du Second Empire de
Napoléon III les melleriaux sont
fournisseurs de toutes les cours
d'Europe ils ont notamment pour fidèle
cliente l'impératrice Eugénie
Eugénie aime se rendre à l'Opéra tout
nouvellement construit à l'occasion de
ces sorties elle fait ses emplettes rue
de la Paix avant de rejoindre ses
appartements du palais des Tuileries
l'impératrice réputé pour son élégance
est une véritable icône de la mode
[Musique]
avait une passion inculte pour
Marie-Antoinette qui se retrouvait
partout y compris dans les bijoux donc
elle elle va favoriser ce qu'on va
appeler le style néo Louis XVI ça va
avec le Second Empire qui est un second
Empire de gaieté de fête c'est le règne
de la crinoline il vous faut parfois 30
mètres de tissu pour faire une jupe et
avec des décolletés très profonds donc
cette modification du costume féminin
entraîne également une modification du
bijou vous allez voir apparaître c'est
longues chaînes de perles c'est sur toi
puisqu'ils vont pouvoir mettre en valeur
la gorge des femmes qui étaient
largement dénudées à cette époque
comme Marie-Antoinette Eugénie connaît
le pouvoir des bijoux ils servent bien
souvent à consacrer le statut des femmes
de Oran en voici un exemple avec la
parure Eugénie réalisé par melerio di
Meller
cet ensemble entièrement fait
d'améthyste et l'accessoire nécessaire
pour une femme du Second Empire cette
parure qui porte le nom de l'impératrice
symbolise le lien ténu entre les
joaillers et le pouvoir politique
au coût des puissants les joyaux sont
les symboles de la richesse de la nation
les pièces qui vont être réalisées par
les bijoutiers joailliers auront donc
aussi très souvent cette symbolique très
très forte ils vont très savouement
symboliser le pouvoir que ce soit le
pouvoir temporel ou le pouvoir spirituel
[Musique]
le Second Empire s'effondre en 1870 la
défaite de la France contre la Prusse
installe durablement la République en
France ce tournant historique consacre
l’avènement de la Troisième République
mais le jeune régime est encore fragile
et a besoin d'argent les républicains
décident de taper fort et choisissent de
se libérer du plus encombrant des
symboles de la monarchie les joyaux de
la couronne
le 2 février 1887 se tient ainsi au
Louvre une vente exceptionnelle
l'idée générale du gouvernement de cette
époque et de vendre aux enchères
ce précieux et incroyable et magnifique
trésor français composé des plus belles
pierres et des plus belles perles en
fait qu'on n'est jamais vu
en vendant les symboles de la royauté et
bien on faisait en sorte que la royauté
puisse reconstituer en quelque sorte et
puis aussi parce qu'on avait besoin
d'argent et qui avait quand même là un
joli Mago et on sait que
les États ont toujours besoin d'argent
un document rare nous permet aujourd'hui
de retracer la splendeur des joyaux de
la couronne car la plupart des pièces
vendues ont été photographiées dans ce
catalogue
ces images sont le dernier témoignage de
ce trésor de la joaillerie
plus de 70 000 pierres précieuses sont
mises en vente elle perdent
automatiquement de leur rareté ce qui
entraîne un effondrement de leur valeur
leur vente a donc très peu rapporté à la
République
on dilapine un patrimoine historique
puisque vous avez des pierres qui ont
traversé les siècles et artistique parce
que quand on les vend on va dessertir
les pierres on va démonter les pare-feu
donc on perd aussi toute une culture
artistique des joaillers donc pour tous
les amoureux de la joaillerie oui c'est
un drame et c'était un drame inutile
l'instauration de la Troisième
République s'accompagne d'une mutation
profonde de la société c'est le temps de
la belle époque
ces années qui courent entre 1870 c'est
la première guerre mondiale sont marqués
par la paix le progrès social
technologique et politique Paris vit
dans l'effervescence culturelle
la rue de la Paix et la place Vendôme
deviennent le haut lieu de la mode la
belle destinée de ce lieu était pensée
de longue date
la place Vendôme
rassemble tout ce que Louis XIV avait
voulu développer dans son long règne
c'est de réunir en un seul lieu le
pouvoir l'argent et les artisans nul
autre ville au monde ne peut prétendre
d'avoir une telle concentration cette
place c'est l'écrin privilégié pour
révéler au monde
l'excellence française
le premier à s'installer sur cette place
et Frédéric Boucheron
artisan joaillier depuis 1858 il est
d'ailleurs l'un des rares jouets
français à avoir pu assister à la vente
des joyaux de la couronne parvenant
tailler acheter 31 diamants dont deux
célèbres mazarins et un diamant d'une
forme très particulière
il achète ses démons ovale et il va
consacrer en fait
26.000 francs or de cette époque c'est
le prix de ce diamant pour l'offrir à sa
jeune épouse Gabriel en 1890 Frédéric
Boucheron loue d'anciennes écuries au 26
place Vendôme un fantôme au passé
sulfureux et squatte l'entrosol c'est la
comtesse de Castiglione l'ancienne
maîtresse de Napoléon III Boucheron
devra cohabiter pendant plusieurs années
avec celle qui fut considérée comme la
plus belle femme d'Europe elle
c'est que ça pile remarquable pour
arriver à séduire autant d'hommes parce
que son premier mari se suicide après
son départ quand même faut savoir ça
c'est une femme qui est très
intelligente qui est très cultivée
puisqu'elle est de d'origine noble
au moment de sa cohabitation avec
Boucheron la Castiglione est une gloire
déchue alors vous avez tous dans dans
l'esprit la légende de la fin de vie de
cette fameuse courtisane qui était
considérée comme les plus une des plus
belles femmes de son époque et va
devenir complètement folle en perdant sa
beauté elle perd aussi son esprit donc
elle va vivre ici cloitré dans le noir
total elle ne sort que la nuit donc on a
un espèce de fantôme qui va rester ici
avec Boucheron pendant des pendant deux
ans en avril
1893 le fantôme qui enfin les lieux et
Boucheron peut ouvrir sa boutique et
accueillir ses nouveaux clients la
Castiglione mourra peu de temps après
elle m'avait vraiment mourir dans la
folie la plus totale dans le dénuement
aussi le plus extrême mais lorsque on va
prendre connaissance de son héritage on
s'apercevra qu'en fait elle a des bijoux
qui coûtent une fortune et qu'elle
aurait très bien pu vivre de façon très
correcte si elle n'avait pas été aussi
folle s'il n'avait pas perdu l'esprit
de son côté Frédéric Boucheron rencontre
immédiatement le succès avec sa boutique
de la place Vendôme
Frédéric Boucheron lui va offrir à ses
clients des choses beaucoup plus légères
beaucoup plus harmonieuse féminine
les révolutions industrielles imposent
la bourgeoisie comme nouvelle classe
dirigeante cette nouvelle aristocratie
est désormais la grande clientèle des
joaillers beaucoup sont de riches
industriels qui pour briller dans le
pari de la belle époque se doivent
d'entretenir en plus de leur épouse une
maîtresse de préférence la plus
convoitée
ces femmes sont de jeunes courtisanes
qui animent les soirées mondaines on les
appelle alors les cocottes ou encore les
grandes horizontales
la Belle Otéro ou liane de pougi
divertissent les hommes en échange de
quelques trésors
il faut savoir que il y a une
cohabitation tout à fait
un peu amusante on va dire entre dans la
journée les magasins de luxe et les
joailliers et le soir si jeunes femmes
qui sortent au bras de leur galon
sont des femmes quand même qui ont pour
certaines une grande culture et donc ces
femmes là ce forumunéré souvent en
bijoux
Esther lakman la marquise de la paella
est aussi l'une de ses cocottes elle est
fascinée par le pouvoir des pierres
précieuses de son enfance misérable à
Moscou elle a gardé le sens de la
revanche à Paris elle se lit aux
artistes comme Théophile Gautier ou
Franz Liszt
et surtout elle va méthodiquement mettre
sur la paille un par un sésamant tous
consentants pour elle les pierres
précieuses sont de véritables assurances
vie
la paella est particulière parce qu'en
plus elle devient une véritable
connaisseur de la pierre et ça
sa connaissance arrive à un point un peu
surprenant c'est à dire qu'elle arrive à
négocier avec Frédéric Boucheron pour
changer une pierre qui lui semble de
moins bonne qualité
ou d'un carat inférieur contre une autre
pierre qu'elle a remarqué qui serait
vraiment à la hauteur de ce qu'elle
attend elle a des diamants jaunes elle a
dit rubis
la paëva est excessive elle affiche sa
réussite en se faisant construire un
hôtel particulier fait de marbre
donnique c'est de dorures sur les
Champs-Élysées
après de 50 ans elle obtient une ultime
récompense son amant un conte prussien
l'épouse et lui donne un titre de
noblesse elle finira séjour exilés avec
le compte dans leur château en Pologne
non sans avoir emporté avec elle ses
pierres précieuses
les femmes comme la paëva jouent un rôle
important dans le changement de fonction
des joyaux avec elle il quitte leur
fonction politique pour devenir de réels
objets de désir et de plaisir
cette clientèle est si importante que
chez Boucheron un lieu très privé a même
été pensé pour accueillir ses
courtisanes et leur riches amants dans
ce cabinet d'inspiration chinoise un
élément du décor attire notre attention
vous avez ici une entrée secrète qui
permettait
lorsque certains clients venaient
accompagner une personne qui n'était pas
toujours leur épouse légitime de pouvoir
s'échapper discrètement si Madame
l'épouse j'ai légitime se présenter au
magasin donc c'était un côté très très
discret et qui permettait de garder la
face évidemment pour tout le monde
le luxe flirt toujours avec les secrets
d'alcove la discrétion est une vertu
cardinale pour ceux qui font commerce de
ces objets si précieux
chez Boucheron en fait c'est un culte le
secret est devenu un culte et la
discrétion est vraiment c'est une une
façon d'être notre maison a toujours
facturé par exemple
les bijoux avec des côtes secret donc
avec des lettres donc de façon à ce que
même à l'intérieur de la maison le
personnel ne sache pas quel était le
prix coûtant d'un bijou
quelle qu'en soit le prix la clientèle
des loyers cherche à être sublimé par
les plus belles créations
[Musique]
voici une merveille de la maison chômée
c'est une aigrette que les femmes
portaient en bijoux de cheveux lors des
dîners
[Musique]
lui il me donne envie de pleurer quand
je le regarde
[Musique]
plus je le regarde
plus je rentre dans le savoir-faire
du joaillier et du sertisseur de tous
ses êtres prodigieux qui ont travaillé à
réaliser un vrai chef-d'oeuvre quand le
regarde
de côté de par dessous à l'endroit à
l'envers il est il était mouvant donc
pour moi c'est c'est un chef-d'œuvre
[Musique]
en diamant et platine qui compte plus de
300 diamants
[Musique]
ou encore ce collier en diamant jaune et
diamant blanc qui a nécessité plus de
600 heures de travail
[Musique]
pour comprendre les origines de ce style
Cartier retournons ensemble au début du
20e siècle pour ouvrir une nouvelle page
dans l'histoire de la haute joaillerie
nous sommes en 1899 trois joaillés et
grands entrepreneurs ouvrent boutique au
13 rue de la Paix ce sont les frères
Cartier ils vont à jamais révolutionner
le monde de la haute joaillerie
il y a une sorte de sentiment d'urgence
par rapport à ce qui se passe à l'aube
du XXe siècle c'est-à-dire la notion de
progrès
la vitesse le transport l'électricité
l'éclairage électrique et tout d'un coup
on se dit mais
artistiquement dans les arts décoratifs
il n'y a pas quelque chose qui se passe
qui est à la hauteur des espérances que
ce progrès qui est vu comme une chose
extrêmement positive laisse donc espérer
l'éclairage public change le regard sur
les bijoux les commerçants des rues de
Paris sont désormais accessibles à tous
les premières vitrines apparaissent et
les frères Cartier voient les limites du
travail de l'or ils imposent un métal
plus discret et plus souple le platine
en voici un exemple avec ce devant de
corsage qui date de 1907 ce type de
bijou disparaîtra avec la Première
Guerre mondiale quand le corps des
femmes se libérera du corset
donc ça c'est ce qui va valoir à
quartier sont grands succès
international et qui va faire que la
maison va devenir la plus grande maison
de joaillerie au monde en quelques
années et ça c'est vraiment lié à au
platine associée à ce style qui va être
caractérisé par l'appellation style
guirlande en raison cette ornement très
Louis XVI de ces guirlandes de fleurs ou
de feuilles qui ornent les bijoux qui
permettent d’ailleurs des jeux de
mobilité à l'intérieur du bijou
[Musique]
mais le style est en perpétuelle
mouvement les frères Cartier sont des
précurseurs comme le montre ses deux
broches datées de 1907
[Musique]
on va laisser place encore une fois à la
géométrie au seul pouvoir d'évoluent et
de la ligne au moment où ce style va
être diffusé à très grand échelle et non
seulement en France à d'autres publics
mais aussi à l'international c'est
vraiment le début de ce qui va faire
Flores dans le monde dans le monde
entier lui Louis Cartier j'entends se
tourne vers d'autres inspirations
après les horreurs de la Grande Guerre
s'ouvrent les brillants de années folles
propices au voyage abordent des grands
paquebot les fortunés du monde entier
traversent les océans il n'est alors un
échange artistique très fécond entre
Orient et Occident
une nouvelle clientèle débarque rue de
la Paix ce sont les grandes familles
indiennes qui vont trouver chez les
joaillers parisiens un savoir-faire
inégalé comme ici chez Chaumet
ce bijou a été
réalisé pour une très grande dame
indienne des datitata originaires de
Bombay et ce sautoir lui a été offert
par le maharaja denda
ce bayadère est un incroyable sautoir
composé de milliers de semences de
perles fines
[Musique]
le bayadère
c'est le summum de la sophistication
imaginée dans lui allait rechercher ce
petit tout petit objet en plus il faut
le ramasser le trouver il faut ensuite
le percer et ensuite après il faut
l'enfiler sur un fil de soie avec une
aiguille tellement fine qu'elle est
courte c'est complètement fou c'est
c'est comme réalisé je sais pas le Taj
Mahal avec des allumettes
c'est quelque chose qui dit mais mon
dieu cette femme qui a choisi un bijou
aussi
raffinée elle doit être extraordinaire
c'est ça qui me fait rêver
un autre exemple de ces échanges
franco-indiens se trouvent dans la
collection Cartier en 1925 le maharaja
de petiala propriétaire de mine de
pierre précieuses passe une commande
extraordinaire le maradjat patiella
arrive à Paris avec des coffres de
pierre précieuses c'est-à-dire non
seulement des coffres de pierre
précieuse mais aussi des coffres de
joaillerie de de sa famille et de son
état
des pierres venus d'Orient et un
savoir-faire occidental donne naissance
au plus grand collier jamais réalisé
et ce bijou est destiné à un homme
on parle de ce collier parce qu'il
comporte un nombre de diamants
incroyable plus de 1000 carats de
diamants mais on compose un collier de
cérémonie qui doit être suffisamment
important pour être vu de loin sur le
Maradja lors des cérémonies c'est-à-dire
que là effectivement on est sur le bijou
qui est synonyme du pouvoir du du
personnage qui va qui va le porter
quartier aime parer les puissants des
plus beaux joyaux du monde voici le plus
grand saphir jamais taillé dans
l'histoire de la joaillerie
[Musique]
478 carats et un bleu perçant qui inonde
l'ensemble de la pierre
[Musique]
une merveille achetée par la reine Marie
de Roumanie en 1921 que ce soit chez
quartier Boucheron mais les Rio Chaumet
ou van clef les pierres précieuses sont
l'essence même des joyaux
éclatantes rares et envoûtante elles
font tourner les têtes des chercheurs de
pierre comme Thierry Robert qui
travaille depuis 45 ans pour la Maison
Boucheron c'est la pierre qui me saute
aux yeux
et je vais aujourd'hui je suis capable
si vous voulez d'être aussi éblouie par
une pierre de deux carats que par une
paire de vincarra c'est pas la grosseur
c'est pas parce que on va c'est une
pierre plus exceptionnelle que l'autre
non la pierre me parle et ça j'ai besoin
quelque part moi de tomber un peu
amoureux de des matières que j'ai en
face de moi
[Musique]
donc dans notre métier ce qui est
extraordinaire c'est qu'on nous
travaillons qu'avec des matières
naturelles nous n'avons pas d'usine ou
on appuyé sur un bouton pour dire je
j'ai besoin de 10 rubis saphir disons
non ça n'existe pas la l'usine que nous
avons elle s'appelle la Mère Terre donc
c'était extraordinaire mais on ne sait
pas ce qu'elle va nous réserver
[Musique]
diamant Rubis Saphir ou encore émeraude
viennent des quatre coins de la planète
et c'est dans les mains des artisans de
la place Vendôme qu'elle révèle tout
leur éclat je vais lui donner une vie
que cette pierre n'avait pas
brillance une qualité si vous voulez de
taille qui fait que même un néophyte en
voyant la pierre mais c'est super
[Musique]
de la roche volcanique au vitrines des
joaillers les pierres ont connu mille
vies et porte le secret de l'éternité
pierre quand elle est belle elle est
presque besoin de rien
sur un anneau et c'est la pierre qui qui
vit c'est elle qui fait rêver
et puis bon j'irai avec la plus belle
écrin que l'on a pour nos pierres ce
sont les femmes
[Musique]
ce quartier une femme exceptionnelle a
su mettre en valeur ses pierres
précieuses il s'agit de Jeanne Toussaint
la directrice artistique de la maison à
partir des années 30 je me trouve ici
dans son bureau où elle a su donner le
temps d'un style nouveau le style
animalier l'esprit de Jeanne Toussaint
est toujours présent dans les créations
contemporaines comme le montre ce
collier ou la panthère est à l'honneur
[Musique]
dans les années 30 tous les joaillés
développent de nouvelles techniques et
créer des bijoux faciles à porter et
multifonctions avant d'entrer dans les
détails et de revenir sur l'histoire de
la joellerie j'aimerais vous montrer une
pièce exceptionnelle ici chez Cartier ce
collier avec en son centre une agate
sculptée remarquable il témoigne de la
virtuosité des artisans qui dit hier à
aujourd'hui crée des merveilles
[Musique]
la dernière née des grandes maisons de
joaillerie et la maison vankley fait
harperse fondée en 1906 elle est née de
l'histoire d'amour entre Estelle harpe
la fille d'un négociant en pierre
précieuse et Alfred van clef le fils
d'un diamantaire
la maison prend ses lettres de noblesse
dans les années 30 quand elle se
distingue par ses prouesses techniques
on est en pleine période industrielle
donc il y a beaucoup cette idée de
d'innover d'expérimenter d'essayer qu'on
va retrouver dans les ateliers de
joaillerie comme on le retrouve dans
beaucoup beaucoup de domaines donc il y
a cet état d'esprit là où il faut
découvrir inventer innover à la fois
cette cette idée de développer un style
avec
une grande richesse d'inspiration et de
l'associer à une innovation technique
permanente
[Musique]
en 1933 la maison dépose un brevet celui
du serti mystérieux cette technique de
taille de pierre est la signature de la
maison
[Musique]
seul 4 lapidaire en France on se savoir
faire pour des raisons de sécurité ces
artisans doivent rester anonymes
assister à ce travail est donc un vrai
privilège
le rubis c'est vraiment la pierre idéale
pour le mystérieux la couleur
résiste au petit traumatismes qu'on fait
subir en faisant la rainure en dessous
on fait cette rainure en dessous pour
glisser
[Musique]
la pierre se sont rails donc la pierre
coulisse
comme ça sur le rail
c'est quand même un don de la nature une
pierre précieuse un don rare en plus
donc il faut le il faut le respecter
ça doit vraiment être un ajustage
parfait la pierre perd plus de la moitié
de son poids lors de la taille une
pierre nécessite en moyenne 4 heures de
taille
cette broche comporte une centaine de
rubis
oui je trouve ça je trouve ça assez
magique quand même
[Musique]
la maison vankleif et arpols va
développer des bijoux agréables à porter
au quotidien et adapté aux tenues des
femmes modernes le plus bel exemple est
ce collier zip
pour moi capture beaucoup d'éléments de
l'esprit de la maison et aussi de ce
qu'elle peut être l'esprit de joaillerie
au 20e siècle
il y a un dessin très avant-gardiste qui
part d'un élément technique si on parle
d'une fermeture éclair qui est vraiment
un élément qui est purement fonctionnel
au début qui a aucune vocation
esthétique et on essaie de le
transcender par le dessin par la
technique par par les pierres précieuses
pour en faire un objet de beauté
ce collier inspiré par la mode est liée
à l'une des grandes clientes de la
maison Van clef Wallis Simpson la
duchesse de Windsor
riche Américaine sulfureuse elle est
l'épouse de l'éphémère roi Edouard VIII
c'est pour elle qu'il renonce au trône
d'Angleterre les ateliers van clef et
Arpels mettront plus de 15 ans à mettre
au point le zip
on sait qu'elle était une amie d'Alsace
qu'apparelli qui était dans cette
célèbre couturière d'origine italienne
ce qui a parillick était la première
couturière avoir utilisé un zip sur une
robe on sait qu'elle se connaissait
toutes les deux et on pense que c'est
justement à la faveur de de cette
rencontre avec Alsace qui à Paris lit
qu'elle aurait voulu porter un collier
qui aurait été un véritable trompe
l'oeil je dirais d'une fermeture éclair
la duchesse de Windsor est reconnue pour
son goût avant-gardiste et reste une
figure emblématique de l'élégance
la duchesse de winstore est un cas
particulier parce que en fait c'est un
couple qui aimait les bijoux c'est à
dire que son mari le duc de Windsor lui
a offert des bijoux et c'est lui aussi
intéressé à la création de bijoux donc
c'est véritablement quelque chose qui
avait en commun
cette femme très controversée apporte un
véritable élan à la joaillerie des
années 30 et 40 ses envies la font
également se tourner vers l'autre
grandjoyer la maison Cartier
c'est du 24 a toujours eu conscience de
son rôle de représentation mais de notre
côté il ne faut pas
sous-estimer
son goût particulier pour la joaillerie
à la fois dans la joie ride pour ce
qu'elle avait de plus précieux c'est à
dire les des pierres extraordinaires
mais aussi dans ce que la joaillerie
pouvait avoir de d'expression la plus
originale la plus intime et de plus
j'allais dire de plus ludique
[Musique]
bijoux ludique rencontre celui de la
directrice de la création de la Maison
la discrète Jeanne Toussaint
[Musique]
c'est elle qui donne un nouveau souffle
à la joaillerie parisienne en créant son
bestiaire dont la célèbre panthère que
la duchesse de Windsor ne quittait
jamais
ces objets sont précieux mais aussi
permettent d'évoquer parfois avec humour
certains événements ou certains aspects
de son caractère donc en cela elle est
comment dire extrêmement pionnière
avec des femmes comme la duchesse de
Windsor le bijou change de fonction il
sert désormais à dévoiler une partie de
soi
ces nouveaux bijoux accompagnent un
nouveau mode de vie c'est le temps de la
Café Society l'ancêtre de la Jet 7 de
Paris à New York en passant par Londres
et Venise une nouvelle génération de
puissants et d'artistes aiment s'amuser
se montrer
cette Café Society elle est tenue par
des milliardaires américaines une
fortune qui provient de l'Industrie et
du Commerce une fortune parfois qui date
des années 1830 1880 et donc elles sont
les riches
héritières
dans leur propre société le monde
artistique ce sont aussi des femmes
éclairées éduquées et qui ne vont pas
hésiter à
user leur influence pour faire
travailler les créateurs et orienter une
certaine mode dans la joaillerie
voici un collier fait de 27 boules de
jade venues de Chine ce jade est daté du
18e siècle
lorsqu'en 1933 la milliardaire Barbara
Hutten s'offre cette pièce le jade est
encore presque inconnu en Europe
elle est arrivée en 1933 à l'opéra à New
York en portant un collier de 27 perles
de jadéite qui appartenaient aux
collections impériales chinoise et ça a
donné tout de suite un engouement pour
la jalite on a affaire au jade le plus
beau du monde c'est-à-dire le plus
recherché au monde
c'est la rencontre entre un matériau
extrêmement valorisé en Chine et
travailler par un joaillier occidental
et ça c'est effectivement ça rend ce
collier extraordinaire
la plus fashionista de cette Café
Society et l'Américaine Daisy fait Laos
elle est la correspondante à Paris du
magazine le plus tendance de l'époque le
Harper's bazar
donc vous avez sans arrêt cette
communion d'esprit entre la mode la mode
qui est vue de plus en plus vu puisque
vous avez l'extension de la photographie
vous avez des journaux qui parlent de
mode et qui présentent ces femmes qui
sont les précurrices de ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui les hits girl
élus plus de 20 fois femme la mieux
habillée du monde des effets love fait
la pluie et le beau temps sur la mode
elle lance avec quartier un style le
tutti frutti
un collier fait de rubis d'émeraude et
de saphir toutes les pierres sont
gravées de motifs de feuilles de fleurs
à la manière des bijoux indiens
[Musique]
le 12 mai 1937 à l'abbaye de Westminster
l'Angleterre assiste au couronnement du
roi George VI
pour l'occasion la monarchie britannique
commande à Cartier 27 diadèmes
quartier devient alors une maison
mythique que l'on surnomme le joaillier
des rois roi des joaillés mais nous
sommes en pleine crise économique des
années 30 même la plus fortunée des
courses européennes est ainsi contrainte
de faire des économies l'ensemble des
diadèmes sera donc réalisé pour cette
occasion avec des pierres
semi-précieuses comme celui-ci en
citrine ou encore celui-là fait
d'aigue-marine
[Musique]
les joyaux sont les accompagnateurs
fidèles de la grande histoire ils vont
encore le prouver lors de la Seconde
Guerre mondiale nous sommes en 1940
après la défaite les Allemands occupent
Paris les commandes diminuent et la
créativité de certaines maisons de Haute
Joaillerie va se transformer en acte de
résistance à partir de 1939 on ne
préfère police va réaliser des bijoux
assez étonnants nous avons réalisé des
fourragères qui représentent vraiment la
France l'histoire de la France au départ
la fourragère est un insigne militaire
que les officiers portent à leur
épaulettes il faut imaginer que des
clientes portaient des fourragères
c'était vraiment un symbole patriotique
de porter une fourragère
les drapeaux des alliés étant aux
couleurs bleu blanc rouge ce seront les
trois couleurs choisies pendant
l'occupation par les maisons van clef et
quartier deux des plus grandes maisons
du 20e siècle mettent leurs ateliers au
service de leur patriotisme voici les
rares dessins des bijoux créés en
réponse à l'oppression nazie
un moment donné décide de produire un
bijou qui représente un oiseau en cage
mais n'en disposer un dans chacune des
vitrines de la boutique ici ici même rue
de la Paix montrer un oiseau en cage
c'est une iconographie dans le sens et
partager par tous et qui est l'idée que
la France effectivement est prisonnière
[Musique]
depuis l'été 1940 les Allemands ont pris
leur quartier au 15 place Vendôme dans
l'un des palaces les plus célèbres de
Paris le Ritz les vitrines de quartier
sont à deux pas ce qui vaudra à Jeanne
Toussaint d'être convoqué par un
officier SS suite à la création de cet
oiseau en cage Jeanne Toussaint sera
relâché mais les quelques pièces
fabriquées seront confisquées
après quatre ans d'occupation Paris est
enfin libéré
[Musique]
à partir de 1944 elle dessine l'oiseau
libéré
comme une sorte de vengeance et de de
réponse à ce qu'elle avait subi au
premier chef quatre ans plus tôt là dans
les vitrines on voit apparaître la même
cage la même taille mais avec les portes
ouvertes et l'oiseau comment dire elle
déployée et dont on voit vraiment qu'il
chante
la libération inspirera de nombreux
bijoux dit patriotiques
à partir de 1944 on a vraiment réalisé
ce qu'on appelle des bijoux de la
Libération les bijoux dit de la
Libération donc des flambeaux des
torches voilà bleu blanc rouge
[Musique]
on a des clips infirmières représentant
une infirmière et un soldat on a des
clips évidemment la croix de Lorraine
voilà tous ces bijoux s'équipent qui ont
vraiment qui se sont vraiment multipliés
entre 1944 et 1945 montre aussi que chez
24h son a aussi participé voilà à notre
niveau si je puis dire à la Libération
en 1945 cette pièce de joaillerie une
pendule en ononique ça sertie de Jade
qui avait été offerte des décembre 1943
par Louis Cartier au président Roosevelt
peut enfin sonner elle célèbre lors de
la victoire
[Musique]
après la guerre la France se relève
lentement les grands couturiers les
joaillés Parisiens s'unissent pour
redonner vie à la création française
à la fin de la guerre en 1945 la haute
couture est complètement réduite en
cendres
il n'y a plus un seul morceau de tissu
disponible la Fédération de la haute
couture française qui dit voilà il faut
qu'on montre à la France entière et au
monde entier que Paris est toujours la
capitale de la haute couture et ils vont
décider d'organiser un défilé de mode
il leur revient alors une idée farfelue
pour montrer leurs œuvres malgré le
manque de tissu ils vont faire fabriquer
des poupées en fil métallique elles
seront habillées comme de vrais
mannequins
et pour parfaire ses poupées on va
rajouter des chaussures
anti dévoilettes on va rajouter des
chapeaux on va rajouter des sacs à main
et bien sûr on va rajouter des bijoux
ces bijoux de haute joaillerie sont à
l'échelle des poupées
dans Tous les jouets de la place Vendôme
vont s'associer pour accessoiriser un
modèle de votre couture et c'est comme
ça que le petit théâtre de la mode a vu
le jour en 1945
ce petit théâtre de la mode signe la
relance du luxe et des arts dans les
années 50 la France se remet de la
guerre les bijoux sont aussi un symbole
de cette nouvelle ère le plus souvent en
or les joyaux de l'époque deviennent
définitivement ludique et personnel il y
a toujours je pense dans le rôle du
bijou à la fois une dimension
extrêmement intime parfois très secrète
des histoires qui sont vraiment
personnelles qu'on partage avec quelques
proches et puis une dimension aussi
sociale puisque le bijou et sert aussi à
exprimer dans certains cas un statut
social un niveau social
une réussite
[Musique]
en août 1953 une femme hors du commun
accomplie un exploit Jacqueline Auriol
passe le mur du son à bord d'un mystère
l'avionneur Marcel Dassault rend hommage
à cette femme pilote hors pair en
commandant à la maison Van klafer Arpels
un collier des plus surprenant
[Musique]
sur ce collier en or jaune vient en fait
se poser le fameux mystère 4 et
lorsqu'il est assez vraiment joli c'est
que la traînée de la traînée blanche
qu'on voit voilà à l'arrière de l'avion
est en fait symbolisée par une
succession de diamants c'est un
magnifique bijou et qui est vraiment est
à mettre en voilà en rapport avec
l'histoire de l'aviation et l'histoire
personnelle de de cette femme hors du
commun
pendant que chez Van clef et arple sont
célèbres la prouesse de Jacqueline
Auriol chez quartier on consacre Jean
Cocteau avec une épée aussi rare que
sublime aussi belle qu'excentrique
[Musique]
était venu applaudir dans son dernier
numéro d'illusionniste aura réussi à
rester non conformiste jusqu'au seuil de
l'immortalité
[Musique]
en 1955 l'auteur d'Orphée des enfants
terribles entre à l'Académie française
bien entendu son épée est à la hauteur
de sa distinction il s'est adressé à
Picasso il pensait que Picasso pouvait
lui réaliser son épée et Picasso qui
avait une relation très particulière
avec Jean Cocteau c'est-à-dire faites
d'estime mais aussi d'agacement lui a
dessiné toutes sortes d'épée mais
d'humour je dirais méchant c'est à dire
qu'il y a dessiné des épées balais il a
une qui s'intitulait sick épée ballet à
chiottes
Jean Cocteau c'est bien sûr pris ombrage
etc donc il a décidé lui-même de
concevoir se voir son épée et donc la
figure centrale c'est le profil d'Orphée
avec la lyre la lyre du poète
sur cette épée est
i une cadeau de la grande couturière
Gabriel Chanel à son ami Jean Cocteau en
effet la tradition veut que le futur
académicien reçoit un cadeau à monter
sur l'épée comme un drapé qui s'enroule
sur le fourreau ce sont les rideaux du
Théâtre du Palais-Royal qui sont ici
représentés en platine
enfin à la pointe de cet incroyable
trésor de joaillerie une main contenant
une boule de neige qui est une référence
à son œuvre majeure les enfants
terribles
Jean Cocteau est un homme debout et de
culture il est aussi un mondain qui mène
sa vie d'artiste au gré de ses
rencontres
en 1949 il élit domicile chez l'élégante
Francine Weiss
il restait 10 ans chez elle elle avait
invité pour un été il est il est resté
10 ans il a décoré toute sa maison
de peinture
qui est absolument remarquable
cette femme est une mécène et une
mondaine qui tient des salons
littéraires en vogue en 1954 Cocteau
dessine pour elle un collier en or
imitant un foulard pour réaliser ce
bijou à la fois simple et sophistiqué il
se tourne vers la maison Boucheron
cette création a évolué ce foulard est
devenu un bijou icône de la maison
et aujourd'hui les comédiennes comme
Salma Hayek
ou Diane Kruger se par volontiers de ce
très subtil collier tissé d'or
en fait l'idée du tissage d'or c'est
quelque chose en fait qui revient dans
l'ADN de notre maison depuis Frédéric
Boucheron puisque ses parents étaient
marchands à pied donc on a un peu cette
idée de texture un peu particulière
comme le montre la création de ce
foulard en or la joaillerie est ouverte
à toutes les inspirations elle ne cesse
d'évoluer au gré des désirs de ses
clients et de ses clientes au milieu des
années 50 c'est au tour des actrices
hollywoodiennes de donner le ton avec
l'émergence de la Jet 7 et surtout avec
l'émergence du cinéma on voit apparaître
de nouvelles femmes qui peuvent
véhiculer cette image de beauté de
puissance de glamour ce sont les
actrices
[Musique]
Elisabeth Taylor est emblématique de
l'époque la femme aux Saintes-Marie
s'est vu offrir parmi les plus belles
créations des joailliers
[Musique]
ce collier composé de diamants d'une
infinie clarté et de rubis à la taille
exceptionnelle lui a été offert par son
troisième mari
[Musique]
on retrouve quand même une petite
ambiance de cocotte du Second Empire où
elle se faisait offrir des bijoux parce
que somme toute ça leur faisait une
petite cassette que la vie d'une actrice
est assez fragile et ça n'était pas plus
mal d'avoir un petit pactole en bijoux
et c'est aussi une preuve pour elle
qu'elle comptait elles vont pas à
acheter des bijoux uniquement pour se
faire plaisir mais elle grossit acheter
des bijoux symboles comme Elisabeth
Taylor qui achètera des bijoux
historiques ou qui se fera offrir par
Richard Burton des bijou historiques
mais qui va aussi travailler les bijoux
et influencer la mode
Elisabeth Taylor était à la tête d'un
trésor digne d'une reine en décembre
2011 quelques mois après sa mort ses
héritiers ont mis aux enchères sa
collection de bijoux cette vente
prodigieuse a rapporté pas moins de 90
millions d'euros lors de ses enchères on
a vu réapparaître notamment une pièce
absolument exceptionnelle la pérégrina
cette perle naturelle montée sur une
parure Cartier en 1969 est un cadeau de
Richard Burton à Elizabeth Taylor c'est
un joyau historique découvert dans le
golfe de Panama au 16e siècle lors de la
vente un collectionneur privé l'a acheté
pour plus de 9 millions d'euros
une autre star hollywoodienne croise
avec élégance l'histoire de la
joaillerie nous sommes le 9 mai 1956 en
Principauté de Monaco grince Kelly
épouse le prince souverain Régnier 3
grâce au Patricia voulez-vous prendre
pour légitimer plus
régner Louis Henri Maxence Bertrand ici
présent selon le rite de notre Mère la
sainte Église
quartier fournisseur officiel de la
Principauté depuis 1920 participe à
sceller l'amour de grâce et de régner la
bague de fiançailles de l'actrice est
une création du roi des joailliers
[Musique]
cette bague en platine ornée d'un
diamant de plus de 10 carats et le bijou
le plus intime de la princesse de Monaco
[Musique]
Grâce Kelly demeure l'une des plus
belles ambassadrices de quartier pour
elle il crée de nombreux bijoux toujours
en diamant et platines dont se collier
qui se trouve aujourd'hui dans la
collection privée du Palais de Monaco
le joaillier s'est sublimer toutes les
beautés de la blondeur discrète de
Grasse Kelly à la sulfureuse brune Maria
Félix pour l'actrice mexicaine
considérée comme la plus belle femme des
années 50 au cinéma le joaillier va
concevoir des objets des plus étonnants
en 1968 elle nous a commandé un très
grand collier en forme de serpent et
c'est un énorme serpent taille réelle
quasiment qui a demandé un travail fou
d'ailleurs parce qu'il est totalement
articulé il fait appel énormément de
diamants baguais ce travail de
conception fabuleux et en 75
effectivement elle nous commande un
objet qui doit être un collier mais qui
doit être aussi un objet de décoration
pour sa table alors qu'elle organise des
dîners c'est à dire que ça dit le volume
que l'objet doit pouvoir avoir
[Musique]
et c'est là qu'on lui conçoit non pas un
crocodile ça c'est notre idée mais deux
crocodiles de façon à fermer le collier
[Musique]
j'ai eu de la chance de rencontrer Maria
Félix donc il y a maintenant une
quinzaine d'années et c'est elle qui m'a
dit je suis venu au magasin en 74 74 75
avec un petit crocodile bébé crocodile
vivant dans un aquarium pour donner
l'inspiration à la réalisation du
crocodile et elle a dit à l'époque à son
vendeur qui était son contact naturel et
puis il faut aller vite parce qu'il va
grandir
les crocodiles de Maria Félix se sont
des trésors d'artisanat pour satisfaire
les demandes les plus fantaisistes ou
pour mettre en valeur les pierres les
plus rares tous les artisans de la haute
joaillerie travaillent avec une même
passion nous sommes là dans l'atelier
très confidentiel d'un sertisseur
il est magnifique
qualité excellente
bien de 11 carats
avec une couleur extraordinaire
pratiquement aucune inclusion qu'on
pourrait voir mais mon microscope les
pierres précieuses sont l'essence même
des joyaux c'est pour elle que les
joaillés dessinent et fabriquent le
reste de la pièce
les grosses pierres sont plus
intéressantes parce que
parce qu'elles sont exceptionnelles une
pierre comme celle-ci elle le la pièce
aura été faite pour cette pierre on
n'aura pas trouvé une pierre après avoir
fait la pièce
donc tout tourne autour de la pierre
là je suis en train de sertir le diamant
taille émeraude dans le chaton donc il
faut que je regarde si l'ajustage est
bon chaque pierre a son identité le
rubis le saphir l'émeraude ou le diamant
n'ont pas la même résistance l'artisan
doit ajuster son geste selon la pierre
on peut pas craindre d'abîmer la pierre
sinon frappe pas grand chose on prend
beaucoup beaucoup de précautions
énormément de précautions là c'est un
diamant ça pourrait être une émeraude je
la sertirai même pas devant vous les
modes ça je pourrai pas besoin de
vraiment beaucoup beaucoup de
concentration
après les mains du sertisseur ce sont
celles des polisseurs qui vont donner
tous les Claas aux joyaux
et je pense que c'est un motif de de
plaisir à satisfaction d'avoir un objet
dont on sait qu'il a été réalisé aussi
parfaitement qu'il est possible dans les
ateliers
la réputation des ateliers des joyeux
français dépassent bien largement notre
pays le 26 octobre 1967 le Shah d'Iran
consacre son épouse farap à la vie au
palais impérial de Téhéran la future
impératrice porte une couronne
éblouissante
donc l'affaire pulse était sur les rangs
pour pour réaliser cette commande
spéciale absolument extraordinaire
c'était vraiment une commande spéciale
digne des mille et une nuits
considéré comme des trésors nationaux
les pierres serties sur cette couronne
ne pouvait pas quitter le palais
impérial de Téhéran
donc il a fallu que toute l'équipe de
vente Claf et Arpels moule les pierres
sur place attéhéran et repartent avec
ses moules à Paris pour voilà être à
même de réaliser la monture à peu près
70 voyages entre 1966 et 1977 pour
réaliser cette tiers absolument
exceptionnelle
cette couronne est sertie de 1550
pierres des perles grises des perles
blanches des diamants des rubis des
émeraudes gravées dont une qui pèse plus
de 150 carats
c'est l'empereur le chat d'Iran lui-même
qui a posé la tiare sur la tête de son
épouse Farrah palavie elle ne pèse entre
guillemets que 2 kg et elle-même a
trouvé cette 7/3 assez légère donc elle
s'attendait à quelque chose de beaucoup
plus beaucoup plus beaucoup plus lourd
et beaucoup plus volumineux
aujourd'hui Farrah palavie n'est plus
impératrice d'Iran et sa couronne est
conservée à la Banque Nationale d'Iran
elle fait partie du trésor national du
pays
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nous sommes le 29 avril 2011 à Londres
lors de leur mariage Kate Middleton et
le prince William offre à la
Grande-Bretagne l'image d'un couple
radieux et amoureux
[Musique]
la princesse porte pour cette occasion
exceptionnelle un diadamiste de la
Couronne d'Angleterre
réalisée par la Maison Cartier en 1936
pour la reine mère c'est Elisabeth II
qui en a hérité la reine n'en fait
aujourd'hui profiter Kate Middleton la
future reine d'Angleterre
[Musique]
le destin de la princesse fait rêver
toutes les jeunes filles ce jour-là pour
lui ressembler elle porte tout un
diadème
ainsi lors de grandes célébrations comme
ce mariage royal les joyaux continuent
de nous éblouir de leur pouvoir et quel
que soit les évolutions de la société
les joyers restent animés d'une même
passion pour créer les trésors de demain
[Musique]
Paris reste et restera le lieu de
l'exception pour la haute joaillerie le
monde entier vient ici chercher cette
beauté
[Musique]
sublimes est un slan trésor de notre
patrimoine les joyaux nous racontent
leur époque
leur couleur leur forme et leur
mouvement sont les plus beaux
témoignages du savoir-faire des artisans
joyeux parisiens
[Musique]
grâce à ses bijoux nous portons un autre
regard sur la grande histoire
ils servent les causes politiques il
manifient les artistes et feront
toujours rêver les amoureux de la beauté
ces objets exceptionnels sont à la fois
les emblèmes du pouvoir et des fragments
de vie la création et l'envie sont
toujours au rendez-vous et demain les
joyaux continueront de nous confier bien
des secrets
entre luxe et artisanat d'exception la
joëlerie française comme vous avez pu le
voir est unique au monde grâce aux
principales maisons de Haute Joaillerie
que nous tenons à remercier infiniment
c'est une histoire de France originale
que nous avons pu raconter les mains les
plus virtuoses qui façonnent les joyaux
d'aujourd'hui contribuent à nous
raconter l'histoire de demain je vous
dis à très bientôt pour découvrir
ensemble de nouveaux trésors
[Musique]